life is not a matter of holding good
cards
but of playing a poor hand well
don't judge each day
by the harvest you reap
but by the seeds that you plant
everyone
at some time or another
sits down to a banquet of consequences
the secret to happiness
is a small ego
and a big wallet
good wine helps too
but that's not really a secret
is it
i travel not to go anywhere
but to go
i travel for travel's sake
the great thing is to move
i always have two books in my pocket
one to read
one to write in
there is no duty
we so much
underrate
as the duty of being happy
by being happy we sow anonymous benefits
upon the world
we are all travelers in the wilderness
of this world
and the best we can find in our travels
is an honest friend
keep your fears to yourself
but share your courage with others
you think those dogs will not be in
heaven
i tell you
they will be there long before any of us
so long as we love we serve
so long as we are loved by others
i would almost say that we are
indispensable
and no man is useless while he has a
friend
there are no foreign lands
it is the traveler only who is foreign
the cruelest lies
are often told in silence
quiet minds cannot be perplexed or
frightened
but go on in fortune or misfortune at
their own private pace
like a clock during a thunderstorm
a friend is a gift you give yourself
[Music]
it is one thing to mortify curiosity
another to conquer it
the saints are the sinners who keep on
trying
you can give without loving
but you can never love without giving
to know what you prefer
instead of humbly saying amen to what
the world tells you you are to prefer
is to have kept your soul alive
[Music]
wine
is bottled poetry
[Music]
there are two things that men should
never be wary of
goodness and humility
we get none too many of them in this
rough world among cold
proud people
the difficulty of literature
is not to write
but to write what you mean not to affect
your reader
but to affect him precisely as you wish
you cannot run away from a weakness
you must sometimes fight it out or
perish
and if that be so
why not now
and where do you stand
our business in life
is not to succeed
but to continue to fail in good spirits
the world is so full of a number of
things
i'm sure we should all be as happy as
kings
perpetual devotion to what a man calls
his business
is only to be sustained by perpetual
neglect of many other things
it is perhaps a more fortunate destiny
to have a taste for collecting shells
than to be born a millionaire
books are good enough in their own way
but they are a mighty bloodless
substitute for life
dead men don't bite
compromise is the best and cheapest
lawyer
if you are dissatisfied with yourself
then everything's not lost
we must go on
because we can't turn back
never think about death
because it is already inevitable
if you keep on drinking rum
the world will soon be a very
dirty scoundrel
suicide carried off many
drinking the devil took care of the rest
i sometimes think if we knew everything
we would be more glad to get away
if it comes to swinging
[Music]
don't waste time with someone who
doesn't want to spend it with you
[Music]
to travel hopefully is better than to
have arrived
an aim in life is the only fortune worth
finding
all speech written or spoken is a dead
language
until it finds a willing and prepared
hearer
good and evil are so close to being
chained together in the soul
to be feared of a thing
and yet to do it
is what makes the prettiest kind of a
man
the most beautiful adventures
are not those we go to seek
extreme busyness is a symptom of
deficient vitality
and a faculty for idleness implies a
catholic appetite
and a strong sense of personal identity
sightseeing
is the art of disappointment
all human beings
as we meet them
are co-mingled out of good and evil
the truth that is suppressed by friends
is the readiest weapon of the enemy
the devil depend upon it can sometimes
do a very gentlemanly thing
everyone who got where he is
has had to begin where he was
marriage is a friendship
recognized by the police
fear is the strong
passion it is with fear that you must
trifle
if you wish to taste the intensest joys
of life
a good conscience is eight parts of
courage